[SQUEAKING]
[RUSTLING]
[CLICKING]
MICHAEL SIPSER:
Greetings, everybody.
Welcome to our last
lecture of the term.
We have survived a
semester online in 18.404
and we are going to
conclude our last topic
today, which is interactive
proof systems that we started
last time.
And with the big--
well, the big theorem
of interactive proof systems
is that IP equals PSPACE.
And we're going to
give the main idea
for that in a slightly
weaker theorem, as we'll see.
So why don't we jump in?
So we have been doing
interactive proofs.
We gave an example of showing
that the graph isomorphism
problem, the
complement of that is
an IP, as I hope you remember.
We had that interaction with
the approver and a verifier.
We're going to go
through it quickly.
Not that protocol,
but just the setup.
And then we're going to finish
by showing that this number SAT
problem is an IP
and should conclude
that coNP is a subset of IP.
All right, so let's go for it.
Yes.
So just remember,
interactive proof systems,
there are these two parties,
the prover and the verifier.
The prover has unlimited
computational ability.
I kind of model that as an army
of students perhaps who can--
where we don't-- they
can work all night.
They can use
computational resources.
And the prover,
however, we're not
going to measure the
computational power
of the prover.
That's unlimited.
And so the prover can do
things like find certificates.
It can test whether
things are satisfiable.
It can factor numbers.
We don't care.
It can do whatever
we'd like and there
is no charge for the prover's
computational demands.
OK.
So the setup we had was the
prover and the verifier.
Both see the input.
The exchange of polynomial
number of messages.
And then the verifier
accepts or rejects.
And we had this notion
of the probability
that the verifier ends
up accepting when paired
with a particular prover.
And what we want is that
for strings in a language,
that probability should
be high for some prover.
And for strings not
in the language,
that probability should be low
no matter what the prover does.
So there's nothing
the prover can do.
And the way it kind of
suggests that at any prover.
But whatever the prover's
strategy cannot make
the verifier accept
with high probability.
Just doesn't have enough
information or it doesn't--
it's just not able to
make the verifier accept
with high probability.
You might think of
the prover as trying
to make the verifier accept.
So the P tilde is
a crooked prover.
I don't think that went down
very well with everybody.
So I have it here.
Another way of looking
at it, maybe it
looks a little bit
more like NP here where
IP is the collection of
languages where there's
a verifier, just like we had.
You can think of NP as
having a verifier which
can check certificates.
Here the prover is going
to be like the certificate
so that for strings
in the language,
there's a prover which can
interact with the verifier
and make it accept
a high probability.
And you're not in
the language, there
is no prover, which can
interact with the verifier
and make the verifier
accept with even
more than low probability.
What's important is this
gap, just like with BPP,
between acceptance or rejection.
And that gap is
there because we want
to be able to use the
amplification lemma.
And if there was
no gap, then you
wouldn't be able
to amplify and make
the probability of acceptance
extremely high when you want
it to be in the language,
when you're in the language,
and extremely low when
you're not in the language.
OK.
So I hope that refreshes your
memory as to how that works.
We're going to walk
ourselves through the--
well, through what
we did last time.
But let's set the
stage for that.
So the surprising
theorem, as I mentioned,
is that IP equals PSPACE.
One direction of that is a
fairly standard simulation.
With PSPACE, you can
basically work your way
through the tree
of possibilities
for an interactive
proof protocol.
And you can calculate
the probability
that the verifier
would end up accepting
if you had the best possible
prover that would try
to make the verifier accept.
And you can just do
that calculation.
It's in the book.
You're not going to be
responsible for knowing that,
actually.
We haven't covered
it in lecture.
But it's not very hard.
A little technical, I suppose.
The other direction is
the interesting one,
and that's the
direction we're going
to be moving toward today.
We won't quite get there,
but the way it works
is that to show that
everything in PSPACE, which
is kind of amazing, is
contained with an IP.
So everything in PSPACE can be
done with an interactive proof
system.
And the way that
is done is by using
a PSPACE complete problem, TQBF,
and showing that that problem
itself is an IP.
But we're not going
to prove that.
That would be sort
of the next thing
we would prove if we had
a little bit more time.
But we're going to be satisfied
with just the somewhat
weaker but very similar
statement that coNP
is contained in IP here.
Again, still very
surprising, because you
have to be able to show, for
example, that a formula is not
satisfiable with a prover.
How can a prover convince a
verifier that a formula is not
satisfiable?
Showing that it is
satisfiable, you just
give the certificate, which
is the satisfying assignment.
But how do you show
something's not satisfiable?
It's unexpected.
And the proof of that is
pretty much similar, slightly
is one kind of
technical point which
we don't have to get into.
So it's slightly easier but
very much in the same spirit.
So remember this
number set problem
is you're given a
formula and a number,
and that number
is supposed to be
exactly the number of satisfying
assignments of the formula.
So in particular, a formula's
unsatisfiable, then it
would be paired
with the number 0.
And that's why the number
set problem is coNP-hard,
because you can easily reduce
the unsatisfiability to number
set.
An unsatisfiability
is coNP complete.
OK, so remember we introduced
this notation last time.
This is going to be critical
for understanding this proof.
So let's go through
it once again.
So if you have some
formula, what I'd like to do
is preset some of the
variables of that formula.
So that's going to be a formula
on m variables x1 to xm.
And I'd like to preset the first
i variables to zeros or ones
as I wish.
So I'm going to indicate
that by phi with 0 means
I'm setting x1 to 0 and
the rest of the variables
remain variables.
And more generally, phi
of i values a1 to ai,
which to start
off with are going
to be just zeros and
ones, just Boolean values.
That's going to be the
formula with those first x1
to set to a1 dot, dot, dot
xi set to ai for those i
constants, which
were zeros and ones.
I'm going to call those
presets, because we're
presetting some of the
variables in the formula.
And the rest of
the variables we're
going to leave as variables.
So we get a new formula
on fewer variables
by doing this
pre-setting process.
And we're going to get to
do the same thing in terms
of counting the number of
satisfying assignments.
So remember the notation
number phi is the number
of satisfying assignments.
Number phi with a preset
of 0 is the number
of satisfying assignments
when you've set x1 to 0.
And no phi of a1 to ai is where
you set the first i variables
to those i values.
And then you're going to look
at the number of satisfying
assignments with
those presets in mind.
So there were two facts.
I'm going to call them
identities, because we're
going to rely on those and we're
going to actually extend those
to the non Boolean case,
as we'll see shortly.
So these two identities
say that, first of all,
if I preset, I
think understanding
the first one is clear
just by thinking about it
in the case where i equals 0.
So this is the case where
the number of satisfying
assignments altogether is
assignments when I've set x1 to
0 plus the number of satisfying
assignments when
I've set x1 to 1.
And this just
generalizes that when
I look at having already
preset the first i variables.
So if I preset the first i
variables to these i values,
the number of
satisfying assignments
I get there is the number
of satisfying assignments
I get with those presets
plus the next variable being
set either to 0 or to 1.
And then you add those up.
The same idea.
And lastly, if I set
all of the variables
to values, so I have no
variables left, and I look
at the number of
satisfying assignments
consistent with that
fully set variables,
so there's no variables
left, everything is set,
everything is preset,
that's just whether or not
those values have satisfied
the formula already or not.
So this is going to be
equal to 0 or 1, the number
of consistent
satisfying assignments
with those m presets where
m is a number of variables
is just whether those m values
satisfy the formula, in which
case, I get 1, or they don't
case, I get a 0.
Critical to understand
these in the Boolean case,
because we're going
to generalize this
to the non Boolean
case, and it's
going to be just more abstract.
The formulas are going
to look the same.
We're going to have to kind of--
we're going to
lose the intuition
that those things correspond
to satisfying assignments.
Or counting the number of
satisfying assignments.
All right.
So let's have a
quick check-in here.
So we're just going to
do an example to hope
to nail this in, this idea.
So here's a particular
formula phi.
And now remember,
number phi is the number
of satisfying assignments.
So phi, the number of
satisfying assignments where
I've set x1 to 0 and so on.
And here I'm really
kind of giving you
two options in each
row for the value.
Now you have to check
all that are true.
So it's really going to be at
most one per row, presumably.
All right.
Let's see if you're
with me here.
So the number of satisfying
assignments for altogether,
well, there are two ways
of satisfying this formula.
This is really
like exclusive or.
So either x1 is 1, x2 is
0, or x1 is 0 and x2 is 1.
So one of the variables
has to be true.
The other one has to be false.
And then you're going to end
up satisfying both clauses,
as you can easily see.
So b is correct
in the first line.
Now, if I'm going
to already commit
to saying the first
variable is set to 0, now
how many satisfying
assignments can there be?
Well, the second
variable just has
to be set to 1 in
order to satisfy.
So now there's going to be
only one satisfying assignment
consistent with setting
the first variable to 0.
Now if I set both
variables to 0,
now how many satisfying
assignments can there
be consistent with
that assignment?
There can be 0, because in
order to satisfy this formula,
one of the variables
has to be 0.
The other one has to be 1.
If I'm presenting
them both to 0,
there's not going to be
any satisfying assignments,
because 0, 0 not
satisfy the formula.
OK, apologies for messing up
that check in on the last day.
Oh well.
All right.
Let's first go over the protocol
we attempted for number SAT
last week on Thursday.
So we're given the input,
the formula, and a k.
And remember what
we want to happen.
We want the verifier
to end up accepting
with high probability when
k is the correct value
and with low probability when
k is not the correct value.
Now, this is going to be, as
you may remember from last time,
this is going to end up
being a flawed protocol,
because it's exponential.
We're only allowed to have
a polynomial size protocol.
But just looking ahead
in this protocol,
the verifier is going
to end up accepting
with probability 1 for an honest
prover and with probability 0
no matter what the
prover tries to do.
So for any prover, the verifier
cannot be made to accept.
So this is kind
of an extreme case
where there's not going to end
up being any probabilities.
But it's an
exponential protocol.
So in that sense, it
doesn't do what we need.
So let's go through it,
because it really sets us up
for the polynomial protocol
with the non Boolean values.
All right.
So first the prover sends--
let's just look at
it and not rush it.
The prover sends the number
of satisfying assignments
according to the prover.
The verifier checks
that is equal to k.
And I think it's
best to understand
this first with the case that
the input is in the language.
So k is correct and we
have an honest prover.
And then we'll
understand what happens
if k is not in the language.
And we'll see that no matter
what the prover tries to do,
the verifier is going
to end up not accepting.
And again, this is just a
setup for the real protocol.
So this is kind of
a dopey protocol.
You're going to think, what in
the world, why am I doing this?
It seems like I'm
making something that's
very simple complicated, but
it's really just the framework
that I'm putting together.
Because, well, you'll see.
All right.
So the proof is going
to send the claim
for the number of
satisfying assignments,
which in the honest case is
going to be the correct value.
The verifier checks that
it matches the input.
Now the verifier says,
well, I want to be convinced
that your claim is correct.
So the prover is going
to justify that claim
by saying, well, the
total number of satisfying
assignments is
whatever it is, 100
because the number when
I have x1 set to 0 is 60.
And the number when I
have x1 set to 1 is 40.
And that adds up to
100, which is what
you would need to have happen.
So the verifier checks that the
sum is correct and then says,
well, now how do I know
those two values are right?
So then the prover unpacks
it one level further.
So breaks those two
down by justifying
that phi 0 was correct,
that value 60 was correct,
by saying, well, now if
I set the next variable,
x2 to 0 and 1, that's going
to have to add up to phi 0.
So maybe to get 60,
I had 50 and 10.
And to get 40 for number
phi of one, I had 20 and 20.
So these I have to add up.
So each level justifies
the preceding level.
We're going to have
that happen again.
Now, the prover says, well, I
mean, I need to be convinced.
I don't trust you.
I need to be convinced that
these values are correct.
So level by level,
the prover is going
to be setting more and more
of the variables in all
the possible ways
until it gets down
to the very bottom where
it's setting the variables
in all possible ways.
So exponentially
many settings here.
And the verifier now checks that
the previous round was correct.
So that's where we set
only the first m minus 1,
the very last variable
hadn't yet been set.
So checks all of
those 2 to the n
minus 1 possible
settings in terms
of the new settings
that we got where
we set those m minus 1
settings, but we extended it
by 0 and by 1.
Again, this is the same identity
that we used from before.
And now that the prover has sent
all of those possible values,
the verifier needs to be sure
that those are still correct.
But the thing is
that at this point,
those are all zeros and
ones because they all
say whether that assignment
satisfies the formula
or doesn't satisfy the formula.
So the verifier can
check those directly.
Checks each of
those, whether just
by plugging into the
formula and seeing
does it satisfy
the formula or not.
So each one of these
is a 0, 1 value,
which is supposed to correspond
to whether the formula was
satisfied or not.
Those all are correct and
everything else along the way
has been correct.
The verifier is going to accept.
Otherwise if at any point
one of those checks failed,
the verifier has already
rejected or at this point
it just rejects.
So that is the protocol,
the exponential protocol.
And I'm not sure if this
is helpful to you or not,
but I like to think of it sort
of as a tree of possibilities.
So these yellow values are
what the prover is sending.
So the prover first
sends the number
of satisfying
assignments all together.
The verifier in
white is checking--
are doing these checks.
So it checks that it equals k.
And then the prover
sends the next level.
The verifier checks that
the addition works out.
Then the prover
unpacks it further,
assigns values to the
first two variables,
and the verifier checks that
just the assignments, just
a single variable are
consistent with that and so on.
And to assign all m variables
and then it checks directly
with the formula.
Now, what happens--
and here is the case.
It's going to be important
to understand in both here
and in the non Boolean case.
What happens if we had an
incorrect value for the input?
And what I want to show you is
that the prover is going to--
I want to show you
that the verifier is
going to end up rejecting
in this case with certainty.
Later on it's just going to
reject with high probability.
But for this protocol, it's
going to accept with certainty.
And why is that?
Because first of all, if
the prover, if k was wrong,
so I'm indicating the
wrong values in red.
If k was wrong, so it did not
equal the number of satisfying
assignments, if the prover
sends the correct value,
the verifier is just going
to say it doesn't match up.
I reject right away.
So what can the
prover possibly do
to prevent the verifier
from accepting?
You're going to see that
there's nothing you can do.
But later on, there's a chance
that the prover can get lucky.
But here there's
nothing you can do.
Let's try to humor me and see--
let the prover try to manage
to keep the verifier going
as long as possible.
So the prover in order
to prevent the verifier
from rejecting at
the beginning would
have to lie about the number
of satisfying assignments.
But then the prover is
going to say, well, OK,
you're claiming there's only
99 satisfying assignments.
Prover doesn't know what
the right real answer is.
But we know it was
100, let's say.
But let's say k was equal to 99.
The prover claimed it's 99 now.
And so the verifier
says, OK, well, it's 99.
Convince me of that.
So now the prover
is going to have
to say the number of
satisfying assignments for 0
and the number of satisfying
assignments for 1,
they have to add up.
At least one of those
has to be wrong,
because you can't have the
two correct values adding up
to the false value.
So a lie here has to yield
a lie in at least one
of those two places.
And then a lie there
is going to have
to yield a lie in one
of those two places,
just like each lie kind
of forces more lies.
As you know, you're
trying to lie.
The story gets more and
more complicated in order
to try to justify all this.
And so in the end, you're
going to get an inequality.
And the verifier is going
to end up rejecting.
Somewhere along
the line, there's
going to have to
be an inequality,
if not along the way
then at the very end
when the verifier
does the check itself.
Because one of those, you
could trace that down, there's
going to be lies
and lies and lies
and then there's going to
be at the very bottom one
of these values is
going to be wrong.
And when the verifier
checks them all,
it's going to find out that
there is an inequality there.
And so one of those
checks is going to fail.
So I'm getting
one question here.
Why is this any better
than just checking
all possible assignments
without a prover?
It isn't.
The only reason
I'm doing this is
to get us ready for the
arithmetized protocol
where we have non
Boolean values coming in.
So questions on this?
I think it's important
to understand this one.
Don't ask the question why.
The why is just going
to be we are getting
ourselves ready for
something later,
which you don't know yet.
But I want you to understand
it for what it is,
even if it seems
unnecessarily complicated.
OK, so let's keep going.
So how are we going
to fix that protocol
so it's not exponential?
So again, here is a picture
of that exponential protocol.
And we have that
exponential blow
up occurring because
at every stage,
each value is going to be
justified in terms of two
values at the next stage.
So it's going to be
exponentially many values
after a while.
So instead, we're going to
try to justify each value here
in terms of just a single
value at the next stage.
But it's not going to
be good enough just
to pick either the 0
or the 1 at random.
Because it might be each--
there might be just
a single course
of lies going through here.
And the only way you
would be to catch that
would be to guess correctly at
each stage which was the lie.
And then you would
catch it at the end.
If you're just going
to be randomly picking
zeros and ones, you're
not going to have
a high probability of catching
the prover when it's lying.
And so that's not going
to be good enough.
The input might
be the wrong value
and you might have
a prover which
just has one path of lies,
and then your probability,
you would still have
a high probability
of accepting in that case, even
though the input was wrong.
It's not what you want.
When the input is
wrong, you have
to have only a tiny chance, a
very small chance of accepting.
So the way we're
going to achieve
that is by having these--
instead of picking a 0 or a
1 for these random values,
we're going to have non Boolean
assignments to the variables.
And we have to
make sense of that.
And we've already seen
an example of that.
It's going to be
very much the same.
All right.
Are we all together here?
So this is a place
where we could
try, if you have a question,
we can try to answer that.
Are we good?
Let's keep moving.
OK, so how are we going to
arithmetize Boolean formulas?
It's, again, the same
idea we had before.
Simulating ands and ors
with plus and times.
So we had this from
before, same exact picture.
Actually it's even
simpler, because now we're
going to be using the true
simulation of or instead
of some kind of a special
case simulation of
or, which we had in the
branching program case.
So these faithfully
do what and and
or does when you plug in 0
for false and 1 for true.
So that means that we can
take an entire formula
and arithmetize it.
The formula built out of
ands and ors and negations.
And you're going to get a
polynomial that comes out.
And that polynomial, what's
going to be important for us
is not going to be of
extremely high degree.
The actual degree is going
to be at most the length
of the formula in terms of
the number of symbols it has.
You can check that on your own.
But for now you
can just trust me.
The degree of the polynomial,
because it only goes up
during the multiplications,
but the degree doesn't
become too big.
And we're going to be doing--
and I don't want this to
be a confusing issue here.
We're going to be doing--
but we have to be correct.
I don't want to
be cheating here.
So all of the arithmetic is
going to be done in a field.
So we have to do plus and
times mod some number, which
turns out needs to be a
prime number for reasons
I'm not going to get into.
But it doesn't really matter.
It's just modular arithmetic.
And that's one
thing that enables
us to pick random
values in a natural way,
because there's only finitely
many values in the field.
And so you're just going
to pick one at random.
But here we want to
be able to represent--
it's going to be more important
for us to have a larger
field, because we want
to be able to represent
the number of satisfying
assignments which
can be a number between
0 and 2 to the m.
So we have to have a
field which has at least 2
to the m elements in it so
that we can in a sensible way
write down those numbers.
Let's not get
caught up with that.
But we can try to answer those
questions offline if you want.
But just think about
it for this first pass.
We're doing the
arithmetic mod sum prime.
So now we have the same notion
of presets as we had before.
So if we have a formula and
we preset some of the values
but now those values may
be non Boolean values.
We may be plugging in
values for the formula.
Not just zeros and ones, but
we might be plugging in sevens
or 23's or whatever.
And the formula is
going to in order
to have a value,
a meaning to that,
we're going to treat that
formula as the polynomial
from the arithmetization.
And just plug in those
values into the polynomial
and see what the
polynomial does for you.
So here we're going
to be presetting
some of the values of the
formula like we did before.
And now it's going
to be the same thing.
But now in the
polynomial, we're going
to be pre-assigning some of
the values of the variables
to these a's from the field.
And the remaining variables
are going to stay as unset.
Now we have to give
an interpretation.
So the new polynomial here.
So I'm getting a question.
Well, maybe I better take this.
Let me hold off on that
for now what the degree is.
I'll answer the
questions in a second.
So now remember from
before, number phi
was the number of
satisfying assignments when
I preset the first i values.
It no longer makes sense to talk
about satisfying assignments,
because these values may
no longer be Booleans.
So I'm going to have
to write this formally
as I'm going to plug in
those values, those i values,
for the first i variables.
And the remaining are
variables which I have not set.
I'm going to assign
them to zeros and ones
in all possible ways.
Only to zeros and ones.
Because what I want to
have, you might think, well,
why aren't we assigning these
to other values in the field?
Well, because what I'm aiming
at is that if I were to plug
in zeros and ones at this
point into the polynomial,
I'm supposed to get exactly the
same values as I had before,
because I'm simulating
and's and or's.
So I'm just extending the
definition, the evaluation
into a new realm.
But I shouldn't
change the values
on the old Boolean realm.
So I'm going to be adding up the
unassigned, the unset variables
in all possible Boolean ways.
And the first i values
could be non Boolean values.
So you have to just accept
this as an abstract notion.
No longer has an interpretation
as satisfying assignments.
So as I said,
what's important is
that if I happen to put
Boolean values in now,
then phi and number phi
give the same values
as they would have before.
Because the polynomial
acts identically
to the formula on
Boolean values.
OK.
So this is what I'm
repeating what I said.
And there's another point
that also you have to check,
which is that the identities
that we had earlier
that connected up what happens
when I set the first i values
and I set the first i plus
1 values, those still hold.
So if I set the first i values
now to possibly some non
Boolean assignment,
that's what I
get when I extend those values
to one more variable being
assigned.
But I just need to assign
that variable to 0 and to 1
and add those up
because of the way
I've defined things over here.
So I've assigned those variables
to zeros-- the unset variable
to zeros and ones when I'm
defining the number phi
function.
And then lastly, when
I assign everything
now to possibly non Boolean
values, that's going to be--
there's no longer
anything to add up.
So I'm going to get exactly
the same as I got from
before when I--
so assigning number phi
of totally preset input,
it's the same as phi with
a totally preset input.
Because in that case,
there are no variables
left to add up over.
So there's just one.
I just get one single.
I sum it as just
one element in it.
So I got a question
here for earlier.
What happens to the
degrees of the polynomials?
Well, the degree
of number phi is
going to be at most
the degree of phi,
because I'm just
adding things up.
And addition doesn't
change degrees.
As I preset values, the
number of variables goes down,
but the degree may not
necessarily go down.
So the question was I got are
the new polynomials having
lower degrees?
Not necessarily.
They have fewer variables
but not a smaller degree.
So let's do this check.
Let's see if that--
now again, this is I think
I have messed up on this.
Well, there's one
of these that's--
I'll give it away in part.
There's only one of them
that was true anyway.
So you can check the one
that's true according
to the way we've defined it.
So this is a little
bit of a trick question
here, as I'll explain.
But there's only
one of them that
faithfully does
the arithmetization
as I described on this page.
And that's the one
you should check.
So remember, over here
this is the formula.
This is the recipe for how
I'm doing the arithmetization.
This whole process here.
So one of these lines,
one of these, a, b, or c,
corresponds to doing that.
I'm going to close this down.
So are we all in?
Yeah.
So a is the correct answer.
A does the arithmetization
according to the recipe
that I just described.
Because if you look
at x1 or x2, we
can just check it in the very
first part of the polynomial.
x1 or x2.
Well, it's x1 plus x2
minus the product x1 x2.
So you can just
see it right there.
The others don't have that.
And similarly for
x1 bar and x2 bar.
It becomes 1 minus
x1, 1 minus x2,
and then the product of those.
So a is pretty straightforward
as the arithmetization of phi.
Now, in fact, any
of those would work.
I don't want to
confuse you here.
But any of those would have
worked, because they all agree
on the Boolean assignment.
And that's all that
really matters.
So if you have any--
all I care about
is that they agree.
The formula agrees
with the polynomial
and the Boolean
cases, and these all
happen to agree
and zeros and ones.
Doesn't matter though.
I put those there just
in case you tried it
by just substitution
of zeros and ones in.
You might have picked
the wrong thing.
OK.
So let's take a break
here, and then we
will see about how to go
about fixing the protocol
after the break.
All right.
So also happy to
take any questions.
We haven't really
done a whole lot.
We basically, this
has all been review
of what we did last time.
But let me start the timer.
But feel free to ask questions.
I'll tell you where we're going.
This whole proof
really comes down
to understanding
one line, which is
going to be in the second half.
So I'm really kind of--
this is all big
setup here to get
you ready to be able
to understand that one.
I'll tell you when it's coming.
So you won't have to
worry that you'll miss it.
But that line is not
easy to understand.
So I think it's important
to get all of the framework
and all of the context all
set up for you so then you
can understand that line and
hopefully you see that line
and understand it.
OK, so the important fact.
So let's go back.
You wanted to see
the important fact.
OK.
So this is what I
was saying before.
If I plug in Boolean values
into the arithmetization,
I get the same exact
thing as I would
have if I applied the
Boolean operations before I
did the arithmetization.
So plus and times in
the arithmetization
give a faithful simulation
of and and or according
to these little formulas.
That's all I'm saying with this.
And so if I plug in
Boolean values for the a's
I get exactly the same as I
would have gotten before I
did the arithmetization.
Because the arithmetization
is a faithful simulation.
Not sure how else to say it.
Let's see.
What does the or rule now--
why does the or rule now
contain the minus ab term while
the previous instance of
arithmetization didn't?
Remember in the case
of branching programs,
we didn't need the
minus ab term over here.
And that was because we could
argue that it was a disjoint
or in the case of the
branching programs.
I don't want to get confusing by
trying to explain why that was.
But in that earlier case, we
never took an or of two ones.
It was an of 0, 0 or possibly
0, 1 or possibly 1, 0.
So therefore we never
had to deal with a case
when we had an or of a 1, 1.
And here we can have that.
So we have to subtract
off that ab term,
because otherwise we'd have--
if we just had a plus
b, then the 1, 1 case,
we would end up with a 2.
And that would not be
a faithful simulation
of the or operation, because 1
or 1 should be just 1, not 2.
So this is a good question here.
Do all the numbers need
to be zeros and ones?
I'm not sure how negation
would work with larger numbers.
The negation, you just
blindly follow it.
Even though we're going to be
plugging in non Boolean values,
it's going to be 1 minus 7.
So you're going to get minus 6.
You have to do that mod P, mod
Q, whatever that value you get.
But you can no
longer think about it
as negation in the former sense.
Now it just becomes
a formal thing.
You're just plugging along
doing what the polynomial says.
Numbers are coming out.
You think this is just nonsense.
But the thing is it's going
to have a meaning that's
going to be useful to us.
That's what this protocol
is going to show.
So you can't think about
it as negation anymore.
It's just negation
becomes 1 minus x
in the arithmetized
world and you just
have to live with that.
Let's see.
Another question here.
If all the phi are equivalent
for Boolean inputs in the check
in, so this is back
into this check in here,
so if all of the--
yeah.
So the question is if they're
all equivalent in the Boolean
case, why is only a correct?
Because I defined P sub
phi in a particular way.
And so this was the value
you got if you follow
the way I define P sub phi.
The others would work, they just
weren't the way I defined it.
Any other questions here?
We should probably move on.
Can arithmetization be
used in other contexts?
Offhand, I don't know.
There are these two cases
where arithmetization works.
Whether there are other cases
too, I'm actually not sure.
OK, so let's move on.
So our timer is up.
The candle has burned down.
OK.
So this was--
OK, here we go.
This is the real protocol.
So I'm going to present it
to you the way I did before.
Let's think about
it with the case
first where the input
is in the language
and we have an honest prover.
So we start off the same way.
The prover sends phi,
sends number phi.
Which in the old
sense was the number
of satisfying assignments.
It actually still is,
because since we're not
presetting anything, there's
no non Booleans in the picture
yet.
So this is going to be
the same value as before.
The verifier checks that
k equals number phi.
So that's why we have to have
a big enough field there,
so that we can
represent numbers up
to the number of potential
number of satisfying
assignments.
But that's a side note.
But anyway, this is
exactly what we did before.
No change.
The number of satisfying
assignments if you like.
Now, let's just see.
Let's remember.
And this is one of those
cases where not having
a big blackboard hampers us.
So I'm just going to remind
you what we did last time.
But I'm going to change this.
So remember before P sent--
and unpacked at one level.
Sent the number of
satisfying assignments
said number phi of 0
and number phi of 1.
And then we did that
check to justify
the previous value, which the
verifier doesn't necessarily
trust.
OK.
Fasten your
seatbelts, everybody.
This is the whole
proof in the next line.
But it's a doozy.
All right.
P is going to send phi of
z as a polynomial in z.
It's going to send
just a single object.
But that object is
an entire polynomial.
And the way it's
going to send that
is by sending the coefficients
of that polynomial.
So let's digest that statement.
So first of all,
let's understand
the value of doing that.
So if I can send the
entire polynomial phi
sub z represented
as a polynomial,
I can plug in 0 and 1
into that polynomial
and allow the verifier
to do the check
that it needs to
do to demonstrate
that number phi is correct.
So it's going to check that
number phi is number phi of 0
plus number phi of 1.
But instead of getting
those values directly
from the prover, it's going
to take that polynomial it got
and evaluate that
polynomial at 0 and 1.
And just to remember,
let's go back
and remember how we defined--
defined number phi
to make sure that we
understand what it means
to have a polynomial here.
So remember, here we're just
taking the very first value.
But you are OK with
putting a constant 0 or 1
and then adding up over
all possible extensions,
all possible Boolean
extensions to that.
And maybe it's OK to put in a
non Boolean value here, like 7.
And then you take the
remaining variables
and assign them zeros and
ones in all possibilities
and add it up.
Now I'm going to do something
even a little wilder.
I'm going to put in
a variable for a1.
Some symbolic, if you
want, symbolic value.
So I'm going to put
in a value z for a1.
So now I plug in z for a1 here.
And a2 through am are
going to be zeros and ones
in all possible ways.
So I just get a polynomial in z.
The other variables get
assigned and added up
over the various
Boolean assignments.
And now I get some polynomial.
So I get some expression in z.
That's just going to be a
single variable polynomial.
Whose degree is it going to be?
At most the degree
of number phi.
So degree is not
going to be too big.
So it sends the
coefficients so the degree
of that is not too big.
So there are not too many
coefficients to send.
So the coefficients are
in terms of the xi's.
No.
I'm not sure what the mean--
the coefficients are not
in terms-- the xi's
are gone at this point.
The xi's, we've
added up the xi's
being assigned to zeros and
ones in all possible ways.
So there are no
other variables left.
There's only z.
So I'm going to do the
same protocol in a more
pictorial way in a minute.
So you're going to see
this whole thing twice.
But try to get it.
You'll have two
chances to get this.
Try to get it.
Try hard each time.
So I've got send phi of
z as a polynomial in z.
Now, that's going to be
enough for me to figure out
what number phi of 0
and number phi of 1
is, because I plug it
in for 0 and 1 for z.
But now I can figure
out what number phi of 2
is also, because I can plug 2
in for z or number phi of 7.
I plug 7 in for z.
So let's stop here and see
are there other questions.
So is the size of number phi--
I don't understand.
This question about
the size of no phi.
Is it 2 to the m?
No, it's not 2 to the m, because
the degree of that polynomial,
number phi of z, I mean,
it's a very large expression
if you want to initially--
yes, it's going
to be an exponentially big sum.
But the prover adds
it all up for you,
and you're just going to
have at most a small number
of coefficients, because
the polynomial is only
of a certain degree.
And a polynomial in one
variable of degree d
has at most d or d plus 1
coefficients to worry about.
So it's not that many
coefficients as an expression.
So shouldn't the summation
take 2 to the m time?
I'm not caring about
the prover's time.
The prover has a
lot of work to do.
But the prover sends phi of z.
So yes, the prover has
an exponential job.
I don't care.
The verifier needs to be able
to check it in polynomial time.
And that checking is going
to, well, we'll have to see.
How does the verifier know
that that polynomial is right?
That's a question maybe
you should be asking.
Yeah.
I'm getting lots of
questions about how much time
the prover needs to take.
Yeah, the prover is going to
have to spend exponential time
to figure out that polynomial.
That's all right.
We don't care about
the prover's time.
Yeah.
So the summation here is going
to be adding up polynomials.
That is correct.
I'm happy to spend time,
because really here this
is the whole proof.
You have to understand.
Well, we have to
understand why this works.
But we kind of
understand half of it,
because knowing that
polynomial is enough to--
if you could certify that that
was the correct polynomial
for number phi of z, then
we can use that polynomial
to confirm the previous
value, what number phi was,
because you just plug
in zeros and ones for z,
and you add it up.
But now how are we
going to justify
that the polynomial is correct?
Because this looks
like even a worse job.
Now we have a whole
bunch of coefficients
and have to make sure all of
those coefficients are right.
And so instead of
just two values,
now we have d values where d is
the degree of that polynomial,
which could be at most
the length of the formula.
So here is the next idea.
So the prover needs to show
that phi of z is correct.
The way it's going to do that,
so even before we do that,
so phi of z is going
to be some polynomial.
Now, the prover may
be lying, may be
sending the wrong polynomial.
How does the prover
convince the verifier
that the polynomial is
the right polynomial?
Well, that seems
like a tough job.
So what it's going to do
is remember that the--
so there is a correct
polynomial that you
would get by plugging
in to this expression
for the correct value.
So there's some
correct polynomial.
The prover may be sending
some incorrect polynomial.
So now we have the correct
polynomial and the possibly
incorrect polynomial.
And the point is
those two can only
agree in a small
number of places
by that fact we proved a couple
of lectures back regarding
polynomials.
So two different polynomials
can agree only rarely.
So what we're going
to do, the way
the prover is going to justify
that this polynomial was
the correct one, is by
evaluating it at a random place
and then demonstrating
that that value you get
is a correct value.
If the polynomial was
the wrong polynomial,
then evaluating it
at a random place
is probably going to disagree
with the correct polynomial
at that place, because
they can only agree rarely.
So the prover is going
to demonstrate that
by evaluating that polynomial at
a random place, that value you
get is going to be
the correct value,
and it's going to continue
to do that in the way,
using the same
protocol, as we'll see.
So that's where we're going.
So in order to show that
phi of z is correct,
the verifier now gets to pick
a random value in the field.
And the prover is going to show
that evaluating that polynomial
at r1 is correct.
Remember this looks a lot
like what we had from before
where we were showing that
number phi of 0 is correct
and number phi of 1 is correct.
Now we're trying to show
that number phi of r1,
this random value from
the field is correct.
So the way we're going
to do that is now
by unpacking it one level down.
And we're going to be using that
identity, because this value
here is going to be equal
to number phi of r1 comma
0 plus number phi of r1 comma 1.
But we don't want to
send both of those.
So we're going to
send them combined
into a polynomial of
number phi of r1 of z
as a polynomial in z.
This is a new polynomial in z.
So now if you understood
the previous line,
then hopefully this one
won't be too hard to swallow.
Because now we're going to
check the identity, but here
by evaluating the polynomial
again but one level
at the next level.
So this is perhaps a good
place to take questions,
because this is the--
this is really what I spent
all the time setting things up
for so that you would be ready
to get this thing hopefully
without--
and hopefully be
able to appreciate it
and understand it.
So I'm not getting questions.
Let's move on a little further.
So now again, the
prover had sent
this polynomial in stage two.
Now the verifier
needs to be sure
that that polynomial is correct.
So it's going to evaluate
that new polynomial
at a random location.
So by picking a random
value r2 in the field.
And now we need to show
that this value is correct,
because if that polynomial
had been the wrong polynomial,
it disagreed with the correct
polynomial almost everywhere.
And by picking a
random place, it's
probably not going to be
the right value and so on.
Until we get to the end where
we have almost all of the values
have been picked, and so
we have one last value
to select a 0 and 1.
This corresponds to the n-th.
It would be great if I could put
both pictures on your screen,
but I can't.
So this very much
corresponds to what
happened in the
exponential protocol
but just along sort of this
arithmetization single path.
So it checks that
the previous value
is correct in terms of
expanding it with 0 and 1.
But again, the 0 and 1 comes
from evaluating the polynomial.
And now the verifier
needs to be convinced
that that polynomial was right.
So it picks a random
value, but now it
doesn't rely on
the prover anymore.
It's going to see whether
that assignment that it gets
by evaluating the polynomial
with that random value rn
plugged in is the same as
what I get by evaluating
the polynomial for
the formula itself
that the verifier
can do directly.
Because this is now a
polynomial now just plugging
into the formula and
using the arithmetization
to get a value out.
So this was the last
line of the identity.
We had those two identities.
So this is the second identity.
And we had to check
that this is correct.
So I'm going to show
this to you in a picture.
Not sure it'll help
if you're confused.
But why don't we take
some questions on this?
So as I said, I'm
going to give you
two chances to understand this.
Because I know it's tough.
Especially with the
constraints of Zoom,
this is a particularly
challenging idea to explain.
OK, so let's see.
So the benefit of this approach
is that the prover only
sends one item for each
depth level instead
of multiple items.
That's right.
But that one item
is the polynomial.
So that captures all of the
values for the entire field.
But taking advantage
of the arithmetization,
that one polynomial has a
lot of information in it.
And what's nice is
that you can check
that polynomial by just
evaluating it at one
random place.
You can check that that
polynomial is correct.
So I'm getting
another question here.
Where does this come from here?
V checks that this here.
So this where does this--
so you have to look--
to understand where
this is coming from, you have
to-- we're at the n-th round
now.
So you have to look
back like at round two.
V has to check that
phi of r1, which
comes from the end
of the first round.
So this checks
that this phi of r1
is correct because that was
how we justified the polynomial
with just a single variable.
The very first
polynomial was correct.
A little hard to say.
But this comes from the
previous round, this guy here.
So this is the polynomial
for the current round.
This is the value from
the previous round.
All right.
More questions.
So why doesn't this run
in exponential time?
Another question I'm getting.
Doesn't V need to check
twice at each layer?
Yes.
The verifier needs to check--
gets two values,
but those two values
come from the one polynomial.
So there's no blow up anymore.
Those two values.
Maybe you'll see it in the
picture that I'm going to show.
So maybe just hold
that question.
Maybe this will become
clearer in the diagram.
So another question.
Does this work because the
polynomial kind of encodes
all the possible
values together?
I think that's sort of true.
It sort of mixes them all
together into one object.
Then you have to
check that one object,
which can be done with this
sort of random probing of it.
So this is another good
question that we'll see
explained in the next slide.
So similarly in
attempt one, the prover
can keep lying by
picking polynomials
by continuing to
pick polynomials,
by lying about the polynomials.
But eventually it's going to get
caught, because this value is
going to be the wrong value.
If the polynomial in the
previous stage and the m
minus--
if a polynomial that the
prover sent in the m stage
is the wrong polynomial,
then you evaluate it,
you're going to get the
wrong value probably.
And so then that
wrong value is not
going to match the
correct value, which
is you can read off yourself
by reading the formula.
I think we need to move
on to the next slide.
All right.
So same proof, version
two, but looks different.
Again, the input is that.
Here is what the prover sends.
Here is what the verifier sends.
I'm going to sort of whimsically
design this as a telephone chat
where they're sending each other
messages through messaging.
So the prover sends the
number phi to start off with.
And then off on the side,
these are the checks
that the verifier is
going to be doing.
So here in our first
round of the chat,
the prover is going
to send phi of z.
Remember this is
just a polynomial
in not too many coefficients.
So it's a polynomial
in one variable.
The degree is small.
So there are not too
many coefficients here.
So this is just pretending this
is what it might look like.
So from that polynomial, the
verifier can plug in 0 and 1
and see that that adds up.
Now the verifier, to check that
this polynomial is correct,
it picks a random value to
evaluate this polynomial on.
And so now it's going to have
to check that this is correct.
So this is nothing to check.
You're just writing this down in
anticipation of the next check.
Now, the prover to justify
that this value is right,
that this polynomial is
right, so we evaluate--
the prover in order to check
that this value is right
is going to send the
polynomial for the next level.
Now, we can from that, we
can plug in 0 and 1 for z.
See if that adds up.
And now to be sure that
this polynomial is right,
we evaluate it at a random
place, calculate that value,
and then have to see that
this value is correct.
So now we expand to
one level further.
We take a polynomial
for the next variable.
And we see that adds up.
OK, I'm not sure whether
this is helping or not.
But we keep doing
that until we get
to the very last round with a
prover sending a polynomial.
Make sure that this
adds up correctly.
And the verifier to see that
this polynomial is right
picks a random value and
evaluates it and now checks
that this agrees
with the formula.
Because we've now assigned
all of the variables.
And then we can check
this number phi directly
in terms of the phi,
because they have to agree.
And so the verifier would
accept if everything checks out.
Let's see what happens.
So this answer will
answer some questions.
Why don't I walk through what
happens if the input was wrong.
And we'll see how
the verifier is
likely to catch the prover
but not guaranteed to catch
the prover in this case.
So if k was correct,
the verifier
will accept with
the honest prover.
But if k was wrong,
so I'm going to,
again, indicate the
wrong values in red.
I want to show you that the
verifier is almost certainly
going to accept
but not guaranteed.
So did I say that wrong?
So if k is wrong, the verifier
is going to probably reject,
but it's not
guaranteed to reject.
So first of all, if the
prover does not lie,
does not send the wrong
value for number phi,
The verifier is certainly
going to reject,
because it's not going
to get any quality there.
So the prover has to lie.
Say if k was 99 but
the real value was
100, the prover if it
says 100, the verifier's
going to reject immediately.
So the prover's
going to say, well,
let's see what the prover can do
to make the verifier hopefully
accept from the
prover's standpoint.
So the prover is
going to send 99.
Well, the verifier
says, OK, 99, fine.
Convince me.
So the prover-- now one of
these two is going to be wrong.
Because the two correct
values can't add up
to the wrong value.
So one of these is wrong.
So that means the prover had
to send the wrong polynomial.
Because the correct polynomial
would evaluate the correct
answers here.
So the prover had to send
the wrong polynomial.
So now when we evaluate
it at a random place,
chances are this is going to
be the wrong-- this is not
going to be the same value that
the correct polynomial would
have given you.
The prover could get lucky.
The verifier might
have just happened
to pick a place where
the correct polynomial
and the incorrect
polynomial agree.
In that place, the prover
will think, huh, I'm saved.
Now I can act like the honest
prover from this point on
and the verifier
will never catch me.
It's sort of a little bit
analogous to the situation
maybe--
I'm trying to see if you really
studied the whole course.
So I'm giving you an exam by
picking sort of random places
there.
But maybe you just studied
a few facts from the course.
You might get lucky.
I might happen to ask
just about those facts.
And then you give the appearance
of having studied everything,
but you really didn't.
So here the prover might
send the wrong polynomial,
but the verifier
just queries that
at the place where
it happens to agree
with the correct polynomial,
and the prover just gets lucky.
And the verifier is going
to accept, in that case.
But there are very few of those.
So that's why the prover
is almost certainly
to be caught if it tries to lie.
But not guaranteed.
So just tracing this down.
If this was a lie, then one
of those two has to be a lie.
So therefore, the next
polynomial has to be a lie.
And so we continue.
So then the next value is almost
certainly going to be a lie.
Not guaranteed.
And so then one of those
two values has to be a lie.
At least one has to be a lie.
Therefore, the polynomial has
to be a lie and so on until--
unless the prover got lucky
along the way somewhere,
which is very unlikely,
even though it
has a several opportunities.
We've arranged it so that
the chance of getting lucky
is tiny at each stage.
So even though he
has a few chances,
there's still going to be
a tiny chance that you're
going to get lucky somewhere.
And so this is wrong, then
chances are that's wrong.
And so therefore, this is
going to be a disagreement.
And the verifier at that
point when it doesn't agree
is going to reject.
Unless the prover got lucky
somewhere along the way,
which is unlikely.
So I don't know if you had--
so that's all I was going
to say about this proof.
I don't know if you had
any questions on it,
but let's just see.
OK.
So do we have any
questions I can answer?
How the prover gets--
how does a prover get number--
how does the prover
get number phi of z?
So you have to--
why is number phi of z
have no other variables?
You have to go back and
look at the definition
of number phi of a.
Because you add up over
all the other variables.
So now instead of a, we're
plugging a variable for that.
But you're still adding up
over the other variables.
So this is a function in just
one variable, because it--
the original thing
was a polynomial.
This is also going
to be polynomial.
I think we're starting
to run low on time.
So this is our very last check
in for the semester here.
So of course there's one
natural question to ask you all.
And for our very last
check in, as we're
in our last couple of minutes
of the course or at least
the lectures, does P equal NP?
What do you think?
Will maybe PB equal NPB solved
by a deep learning algorithm?
Or maybe we'll never prove it.
Give me your best guess.
We're kind of
running out of time.
So let's not think
too hard here.
Another five seconds.
All right.
Ending polling.
I'll share that with you.
Oh, I did share.
So what did we get?
D here.
We will prove it in somewhere
between 20 and 100 years
from now.
That seems to be the
majority opinion.
I don't know.
I hope it'll be sooner
than that, because I'd
like to see the answer.
But we don't know.
Yeah, if you can prove
P different from NP,
I'll give you an A+.
You won't have to
take the final.
But you better be
sure you're right.
All right.
So that is our quick review.
We finished number set in
IP and therefore that coNP
is a subset of IP.
If you're interested in further
pursuit of this material,
I got a couple of
questions on that.
These are some courses
you may want to look at.
I know I checked
with Ryan Williams.
He's planning to teach
Advanced Complexity fall 2021.
So that's going to be the
most natural follow-on subject
to this one.
There's the crypto
classes also are
kind of make use of
some of the same ideas.
And there's, of course,
also randomness computation
that Ronitt Rubinfeld teaches.
If I didn't check with her.
I'm not sure the next time
she's going to be teaching that.
And good luck on the
final and best wishes.
And I'm going to
have office hours.
So if you have any questions,
happy to answer those.
But otherwise, see you all.
Good luck.
Thank you for the comments.
Yeah, I enjoyed having
you all as students.
It was a fun time.
A lot of work, but
it was a fun time.
I've always been intrigued
by the P versus NP problem,
and I proved a kind of a--
I proved the
exponential complexity
of computing the parity
function in a certain weak model
of computation.
So parity function is obviously
very trivial function.
But for the parity function,
if you can't count,
whatever that means,
but there is a model
you can kind of set up
where you can't count.
Then parity requires
exponential complexity.
And surprisingly,
not easy to prove.
But that's probably the theorem
that I'm most known for.
Anyway.
But that would be a
topic for another day.
Another question.
Why not include
Myhill-Nerode theorem.
I don't know.
That's a theorem
about finite automata
and all of those ways
of characterizing
the regular languages.
That seems kind of
a technical theorem.
I don't see much
point in covering it.
And another question that
some of my colleagues
ask me is why don't I
have Rice's theorem, which
sort of provides a
kind of a machine
for proving undecidability.
And I don't know.
I think that you can use Rice's
theorem without understanding
how to prove undecidability.
It's like checking off a box.
Checking some boxes and then you
conclude something's undecided.
I'd rather have
somebody understand it
rather than be able to
use some powerful tool.
Can we understand that
proof about the parity
function that I just alluded to?
It's super hard.
With the knowledge from
this class, I think you can.
That theorem relies
on a certain technique
which we didn't cover called
the probabilistic method, which
is a kind of an amazing method.
Not hard to explain,
but basically you
show that something
exists by showing
that the probability
that a random object has
the property you're
looking for is more than 0.
And so therefore,
the thing that you're
looking for that has that
property has to exist.
There are lots of examples
of that these days.
But it's kind of
an amazing method.
So we use that method.
Do I think quantum computing
can solve useful problems
beyond the capability
of computers?
I have no idea
whether one can really
build a quantum computer.
It seems to be always
20 years off at least
to doing one that factors.
And I've been literally
I remember people
20 years ago saying
it's 20 years off.
So I don't think
it's converging.
I'm skeptical that they'll ever
build a quantum computer that
can factor.
I'll go out on a
limb and say that.
But that's controversial.
And whether it can solve
other useful problems,
I'm not sure what other
useful problems are there.
Well, I guess they're
simulating quantum systems.
So maybe that might be possible.
All right.
I think I'm going
to end this now.
But thank you, everybody.
Take care.
Bye bye.